à la cité des 4000 à la courneuve les
aires de jeu sont désertes et les halls
d'immeubles sont vides
le coronavirus à figer le pays mais les
français sont ils tous égaux face à
l'épidémie
bienvenue dans le quartier on appelle
même brook à la frida kahlo de la
courneuve
artiste peintre et retraités mais brouca
ville confinement au jour le jour je
fais une cocotte de pâtes avec ce que
j'ai jamais assez si j'ai mélangé un
petit bout de poulet avec un peu de
viande hachée
il n'y a pas de lumière dedans parce
qu'elle est cramé bon voilà on chez vos
parents changement depuis le début du
confinement mais bon gars qui vit avec
ses trois fils n'a toujours pas perçu sa
petite retraite
les dépenses sont limitées et les repas
aussi on achète le strict nécessaire
moi par exemple chez moi on mange pas
les trois repas par jour je peux ne peut
pas donc on prend le petit déj comme on
dit que plus je fais une cocotte de
pâtes ou une cocotte bioret ou une
cocotte de lentilles on mange dedans
quand on a faim et je n'ai pas eu les
moyens de stocker beaucoup
donc voilà on vit au jour le jour les
légumes
wima yaourt machin on ne peut pas les
acheter malgré les promesses du
gouvernement mais brouca compte
davantage sur la solidarité du quartier
il faut que nous autres nous humains on
s'organise et voir comment sont très
bien entre nous samson s'entendre dans
la main au gouvernement je sais que vous
allez pareil je sais qu mandanda en rien
des milliers de familles ont perdu leur
emploi et les difficultés financières et
sociales continuent de se creuser à
l'idiot houara président de l'amicale
des locataires à mf clcv de la courneuve
alertent depuis des années les services
publics sur la crise sociale et
sanitaire en banlieue une situation
aggravée par le confinement et des
familles qui ont du mal à payer leur
loyer
les familles aujourd'hui elles ont vu
leurs ressources diminuer mais en même
pas ils ont vu leurs dépenses augmenter
donc à un moment donné faut juste se
poser la question du rééquilibrage
on nous propose des échelonnements mais
ça va venir encore plus accentué la
crise ceux qui ont plusieurs enfants et
qu'on eut des dépenses qui ont augmenté
et ainsi de suite
on devrait les exonérer de loyer au
moins jusqu'à la fin de la crise
sanitaire
le département de la seine saint denis
est le plus touché par le cos vie 19
principalement en raison de la
promiscuité et de la surpopulation dans
les logements hlm puisque tu avec une
maman
ils sont six dans un f2 malgré une
continuité pédagogique inexistante
un possible retour à l'école 11 mais
elle n'est pas une bonne nouvelle selon
l'association
les écoles vont réouvrir et notamment
les écoles des quartiers populaires non
euro en est qui nous en fait veut nous
envoyer un peu à l'abattoir alors que
les justes jusqu'à aujourd'hui les
mesures sanitaires ne sont même pas mis
en place et a fortiori en banlieue
les habitants de la courneuve ont le
sentiment d'être les oubliés de cette
crise ali diouara pointe du doigt la
responsabilité de l'état très
concrètement les services de l'état et
l'état de manière générale le
gouvernement est absent en
seine-saint-denis pour moi c'est même
plus un délaissement
c'est clairement un abandon le
gouvernement a débloqué près de 350
millions d'euros pour aider les
locataires les plus fragiles un budget
géré par les collectivités locales et
une aide accordée sous certaines
conditions
alors en attendant de l'autre côté du
périphérique mais brooke a comme des
milliers de franciliens espèrent des
jours meilleurs